alright so I know that I've been saying
something is all you needed a lot but
this time it is honestly different and Q
Laura is truly all you need for me I
have personally been long annoyed at
like how cold boring robotic and just
sort of dead the current state of AI
conversations are what I really want is
a little personality a little spice and
I want an AI to sometimes make me laugh
the problem is where do you get enough
data such that a model is both useful
and fun like this at the same time not
only that but training such a model from
scratch takes months and millions of
dollars on arguably hundreds of millions
of dollars of infrastructure you could
also do a traditional fine tune but even
then you're looking at weeks and tens of
thousands of dollars so enter Laura or
low rank adapters from Microsoft
research the concept here is actually
based on Research from Facebook at the
time now meta of course and that showed
that as you pre-train models what you're
really doing is lowering dimensionality
the idea here is that after a model has
been pre-trained you can actually update
a condensed version of the weight Matrix
in fine tuning and that's for Laura or
low rank adapters so that research from
Microsoft that's based on that research
from meta the Laura paper showed that
you could actually reduce trainable
parameters by up to 10 000 times and
still be effective for fine tuning the
proposition from Laura is that we can
actually represent that exact same Delta
weight Matrix as we train in far less
Dimensions assuming a pre-trained model
so you can't just simply do this right
out of the gate you need pre-training to
lower those Dimensions imagine you have
a weight Matrix that is 10 000 by 10 000
that's 100 million values that are
contained there if you wanted to
calculate the Delta weights that would
be calculating 100 million Delta you
know weight values Laura or low rank
adapters asks what if rather than having
that single Delta weight Matrix what if
we had two matrices instead a and B and
then we just lower the dimensionality of
those so imagine matrix a is 10 000 by
10 and Matrix B is 10 by 10 000. each of
those is only one hundred thousand
values totaling to 200 000 far less than
100 million and then what if we multiply
these with a dot b we have ourselves a
ten thousand by ten thousand Delta
weight Matrix that original Laura paper
and subsequent research has shown that
this is apparently a valid way to fine
tune a pre-trained model and this means
many things for us it means way less
calculations are required so that
training is actually much faster but it
also means that the memory required to
do this like fine tuning is also far
less as well
and then researchers from the University
of Washington slapped quantization on
top for Q Laura and quantization is just
a lower Precision a much again lighter
weight even less memory is required and
all that and the researchers from
Washington also graced us with a
wonderful GitHub repo packed with
fantastic information and the code to
actually train your Q Laura models the
beauty of Q Laura with all the research
backing it up is that you can fine-tune
models with very few samples again as
low as something like a thousand samples
and in some cases even less especially
if you're maybe trying to fine tune more
for like a structure or something like
that you can use any data you want
in this fine-tuning step it literally
all you're doing is making a generative
model generate whatever the heck you
want and whatever the heck format you
want I made a chatbot here but you could
make next line code predictors or
anything else in the realm of generative
text the possibilities truly are are
just endless here for me personally all
I really wanted to do was like a slight
style shift of the Llama 2 7B chat model
so I went ahead with using Reddit data
and more specifically the Wall Street
bets subreddit from the 2017 era there
are many things to consider with your
data set and you could probably capture
the character for example of a variety
of subreddits if that's what you wanted
but again you can do anything and that's
what makes Q Laura so cool because you
need such a small amount of data you
arguably you can just make up your own
data set you could hand create your own
data set it's it's truly just awesome
for the data set that I use I created
and uploaded the Wall Street bets
subreddit data to hugging face so feel
free to use that data set if you want I
did also have issues with the sort of
end sequence token and I was it was just
like never getting generated and to my
understanding with llama 2 or really all
these llama 2 models they terminate or
have an end of sentence token that is
just a closing tag like a slash S and
from my understanding your data your
training data does not need to include
that slash S I did try both with
training data that did just include it
anyway since that's what the generator
like the tokenizer knows and in both
cases it just never worked it just never
stopped generating when I first trained
the model I actually went to go do a
test inference and I like left for a
little bit and I came back and it was
still doing the exact same thing it had
been doing it for like 45 minutes just
trying to generate one sample it just
never reached a stop token it was very
very strange so anyway I ended up making
my own data set with very clear you know
comment response and tags but these are
not the traditional ones and you would
probably need to add this maybe to your
tokenizer or do something so that the
model actually knows how to stop you can
do all kinds of different stop tokens
and stop sequences and stuff like that
but mostly I was just trying to get an
idea for how Q Laurel worked so this is
what I ended up going with but feel free
to make changes like I said you can do
anything here also as you can see my
data set here is 118 500 rows or samples
but really truly you can do this with
far less I was seeing results after just
a hand like 20 steps of like let's say I
think the batch was like 40 something
like that so 800 samples like truly just
it doesn't take much at all I would also
probably suggest that you prune down
even this data set that I'm using here
in further kind of curate it for
whatever it is you're looking looking
for I again everything up to this point
was just me my first pass through Q
Laura just trying to figure out how does
this work does it really work how could
it possibly work it just didn't seem
like it really could work so I just
wanted to like have a data set and just
feed it through so anyway yeah keep that
in mind this isn't a this isn't like a
terrible data set it that I've done
literally no effort other than just
simply pairing up comments and responses
it is also worth noting that this model
will say things that are culturally no
longer seen as totally acceptable and
likely even in 2017 we're not seen as uh
acceptable by everyone this is also
fixable with removing things from the
training data set that you might deem to
be offensive my objective here was to
just make a more fun chatbot and just do
kind of research into doing Q Laura on a
data set and I really did kind of want a
data set that was far from the norm of
talking purely so I could know does this
actually work and of course in my
research for this project I stumbled on
Yonex GPT 4chan model that is one of the
very few models that have ever been
actually banned from hugging face as
well as receiving what I would best
refer to as a letter of disgust from 360
various researchers and such at various
institutions condemning yannick's
deployment of such a model didn't look
like that was mostly it was like more
about like the training of that model or
it didn't look like it was about the
training of the model but more so about
the the way he went about
just releasing it and deploying it into
the wild on the poor just unsuspecting
people of 4chan uh
anyway
um I'm going to try my attempt was not
to make like an offensive bot or a bot
that would fit into the politically
incorrect uh sub I don't know section of
4chan uh and instead I really just
wanted a bot that was just kind of fun
and that's what I'm really going for but
do keep in mind this one will say things
that uh you might not find appropriate
or to your taste all right so we have
data and again all I did to compile this
data was just I just took comments and
replies and I made a little sample of
them and I stuffed them into a data set
and I uploaded it to hugging face really
no effort is involved here
um I would encourage you to look at
exactly what each sample is it's just
like a big Json object of you know
basically you know the key of sample the
value of that exact sample and that's it
you can upload that as a hugging face
data set and plug it into these the the
script that I'm using here I also know
that I've kind of stressed this already
but I really think that this is so
important is that the format that I'm
using here is not required this is not
the original format of llama27b chat
although I did I attempted to use their
format it's just that it it just wasn't
really work it was never reaching that
end of sequence token and so then I just
decided hey I'll just use these like the
pound pound and then that and and I
found that it did learn that like really
quick and easy you could continue to use
the llama27b format uh again I I don't
know why it wasn't reaching a stop token
though and like I said I did I tried
both including the stop token in the
actual training data which I don't
actually think is you're supposed to do
and then I did it without and in both
cases no matter how much I trained no
how much I tried it just never found
that stop token so if anybody knows like
why it never reached the end feel free
to please do let me know also I never
did any multi-turn examples so there was
no like comment comment comment reply or
comment reply comment reply so there was
no like history of discussion in any of
my samples it was they were all comment
reply I think for a better bot you would
probably want to do multi-turn but in my
testing this did not really seem too
important but I would say that as the
context expanded and there were like
multiple comment reply comment replies I
built out the prompt just in testing it
maybe it seemed that the bot was slowly
straying from the fine tune and going
back to the original llama character but
really hard to say and plenty of times
it does not and so I I think it stays
just not as full or something like that
anyway more research required there but
moving along like I said the data set is
not great and I can't stress enough how
little effort I put into making this
data set and it still worked now all the
cool and smart kids are using Q laura.pi
these days it seems but when I was
learning I found Q laura.pi to be a
little unwieldy and just not totally
clear what was happening I couldn't look
at it and understand what was going on
and that was kind of not useful to me at
the time so instead I used a notebook on
that exact same repo that I think more
clearly broke down every step of the
process so I recommend you probably
start there then maybe you know graduate
to Q laura.pi even this notebook just
simply kind of trains the model for like
10 steps I want to say and then just
stop so what I did was I modified that
notebook a little bit too basically to
the point where every n steps the model
would be sampled on some prompts I think
I ended with like 30 or 40 prompts and
then save both the model and the
responses to those prompts to you know
files and stuff like that so that I
could review them later and then just
train it overnight
one thing to note is every time that you
do this I didn't realize it until later
when I was looking at the tensorboard uh
the trainer that they're using has a
weight Decay even though it's not set
there I didn't I didn't even know that
like the a trainer I guess maybe the
default trainer with hugging face has
weight decay in it so every time I run
that trainer I'm like resetting the
learning rate and then it decays down
and it jumps back up and then it decays
down then it jumps right and sometimes
you actually want this Behavior but if
it's not intended it was a mistake so uh
just keep that in mind as well that my
method here is no good because the
weight or the learning rate is decaying
then resetting then decaying then
resetting it did still learn loss did
actually still continue going down and
all that but again something to keep in
mind but also I've said it a few times
no matter how terribly I did this the
end result still worked
to actually do the training I used an
h100 server on the Lambda Cloud now
because their gpus are so cheap like
half the price of basically everyone
else they are often not available so you
can use my GPU sniper to snag one via
the API if you like they also have other
gpus but pretty much almost always
there's nothing available and so you
have to be able to snipe I will say
though that to train like Q Laura on at
least llama27b for example you can
totally do it on like an 8 10 or those
are very frequently available so you
could definitely do that but if you want
to snipe an h100 or something like that
I have a script for you and then I also
have a simple shell script see that five
times fast that you can also use that
just installs all the base packages that
you're going to need to kind of get
started here so feel free to use that if
you want with the h100 on Lambda I was
actually able to do qlorofine tuning I
did a lot of testing and changing things
around and stuff like that so it did I
ended up spending about a day or so or
two on on this project but the actual
time to like Q Laura a model is a matter
of just hours uh to what I would
describe as fully Q Laura train or fully
Q Laura fine tune rather a model it is
shocking how fast you get results with Q
Laura and of course the h100 GPU is also
quite fast but it's just I'm still just
blown away by how fast easy and it's
just simple Q Laura fine tuning really
is I think uh I'm late to the Q Laura
party as I like started diving into all
this uh I was aware of it but I just had
never done it and I I think that this is
like something that probably a lot of
people are not paying attention to and
uh it I think Q Laura at least in terms
of fine tuning and doing everything so
lightweight uh I think there's big
things coming for for this kind of style
of of training models but wait there's
more this is where they things get even
more interesting than I've said even up
to this point the model that you save as
you train this is what you refer to as
the adapter and it's actually the
smaller condensed version essentially
and the adapter is what you use with the
model when you actually go to perform
inference now the size of this adapter
though for a 7B model is a mere 160
megabytes now this alone opens the door
to all kinds of crazy applications all
you do is attach this adapter to the
model and then boom you have that new
fine-tuned model's behavior and this is
what's leading to the current project
that I've been working on with the group
at Skunk Works where we're actually
training a mixture a mixture of experts
where the
experts are these Q Laura adapters that
you can then just kind of switch around
so rather than say like fine-tuning a
bunch of 7B models and each fine-tuned
7B llama model being six gigs of RAM or
six gigs of memory either on your GPU or
Ram you can instead have
each expert each fine-tuned llama2 model
is only 160 or 200 megabytes much
smaller much smaller not to mention this
also means really you can get even
smaller than that is if you're willing
to raise the number of experts but
decrease the model size you can actually
have tons of experts most people use
models
and they don't like when you're using
gpt4 gpd4 is capable of all kinds of
Realms of education and knowledge and
all that you're probably every time you
interact with gbd4 you're probably
really only using like one percent or
less of gpd4's actual knowledge so if
you could instead just swap out these
adapters and swapping them out is
extremely fast again this opens up a lot
of doors that I think really up to this
point have never really been considered
or even been a possibility at all but
back to our project here imagine that
you see some outputs for your model that
you actually like you could you can
actually run the model in its quantized
form with that adapter right away but if
you want to share that model and allow
other people to run it at whatever
Precision they want or to be able to
convert it to whatever position they
want then you're going to probably want
to release the full model so for this
we're going to need to de-quantize and
we need to merge so to do that I used
the following code when I had used this
code it actually wasn't saving the mer
the final like merged model uh but it
looks like upon reading this script
right now it looks like it's actually
been updated to do that so just keep
your eyes peeled make sure it's actually
doing it
um but from what I can tell it looks
like it actually is so then from here
you're free to upload that model to
hugging face and share it with your
friends and all that so I've actually
done just that I uploaded the adapters
and full models for the Wall Street bets
fine tunes of llama27b and 13B I did
both of these models I found to be
honest 7B and 13B to be very very
similar in terms of like my analysis of
how the the fine tuning went so anyway
use whichever one you want or whichever
one you find interesting or don't use
them at all I don't actually expect
these models to get very much use they
were just something I wanted to do and
try I think I would want to improve
these quite a bit before people really
start using using these models that said
the resulting model in both of these
cases in general is a little more as the
kids say based and has a little more
character it's a little more a lot more
opinion it is opinionated it's a zero to
one step in being opinionated which is
awesome I want models that I don't know
feel like I hate to use the phrase like
feels like a real person or humanizes
the bot because not in like a creepy way
it's just in a friendly way right I want
my AI to be friendly in the way of
feeling uh feeling human not in a creepy
way but it's hard for me to put it into
words but I just feel like right now
when we talk to these AI it is so just
it just they're like dead and cold and
and that's not fun I want to interact
with fun fun AI you know
um it just feels more realistic also of
note these are still just 7B and 13B
models those models in general aren't
really fantastic models right out of the
box although imagine if you had hundreds
of these adapters and you could switch
them around anyways here are some pretty
good examples starting with a multi-turn
conversation again this is a type of
conversation that wasn't even included
in the training data and is using this
brand new format and this format is not
a format that llama2 knows at all but
yet it still works even though it was
only trained on one turn of comment
reply comment reply you are actually
able to continue building comment and
replies if you're curious about the code
that I used to build that prompt I also
have shared two spaces one is for the 7B
Wall Street bets chat and the other one
is for 13B but it's literally the same
code the only difference is the model
that I'm using so in this multi-term
conversation the other thing I just I
just really like about this is it
actually has opinions like I just want a
model like when I ask a question I want
a more of a solid type of answer back
the conversation itself also just feels
more realistic like you're actually
chatting with another person rather than
some chatbot that's been aligned to have
no real opinion or thoughts or cares or
interests or anything like that at all
they're just so lifeless normally I want
a model to have a little enthusiasm
sometimes here's another good one from
the training samples that I really liked
rather than just sort of beating around
the bush the model is just straight up
and honest feeling it does not feel like
some sort of PR or legal rep of some
Corporation and sometimes this model
just makes me bust out laughing on the
topic of a certain company's Apache 2
license change to a non-commercial
license mid project after public
contributions and so on I asked this AI
what it thought about a move like that
and the answer just made me die laughing
it's just funny and I don't know there's
just something about the lack of emotion
and feeling and and a little bit of
Comedy a little bit of sarcasm that is
just not present in the current models
that we have right now and I might even
argue that some of that lack of what
people might call creativity or fun or
play is the result of this sort of
alignment that we're so obsessively just
going crazy about like I I just want to
see more fun models that's all I'm not
saying this model is the best model or
even the best version of what I was
trying to achieve here but one thing
that really has been bothering me just
so long is just yeah these these boring
and lifeless models yeah I don't want
models to be overly abrasive or rude I'm
sorry if my model has offended you but I
do like a little bit of character and I
I hope people make models with a little
more character in color uh than really
what we have have today and and I really
just hope models can genuinely make me
and other people laugh rather than yeah
sound like some sort of corporate PR or
something like that I'm also extremely
bullish on Q Laura fine tuning and some
of the other emergent capabilities uh
with architectures that manipulate this
ability to attach and swap around Q
Laura adapters you know these like
expert adapters in theory and I'm fine
finally finding myself to be excited
about smaller models again we've seen
that like llama27b is very performant
even when compared to models a year ago
of 100 plus billion parameters and I
think that we're closing in on models
that can comfortably run on people's
phones literally on their phone in their
pocket like off no data that kind of
stuff
and actually be useful so I hope to see
more there as well if you want to learn
more about neural networks and how they
work check out the neural networks from
scratch book at
nnfs.io anyway that's all for now I'll
see you guys in another video